Louis I'm your uncle Jonathan home sweet
home
you're perfectly safe that's safe as
long as it's fed my favorite movie
experiences have been in IMAX
especially when the filmmakers like do
special things for IMAX and I know that
Eli has an eye for that kind of thing so
I'm looking forward to seeing on a big
big scratch
I was gonna say the screens giant
[Music]
you'll see it's quite different here
I've always wanted to have a movie in
IMAX and when I saw the IMAX I couldn't
believe it my job was on the ground I
think it's the absolute best way to see
the movie
suddenly the acting is so fantastic in
the movie but even bigger you get to see
like the irises and the I've liked
everything it looks so beautiful so
magical you're just completely thrown
into the world I don't want the creepy
little runt think I want
[Music]
I can only imagine it's going to be
thrilling there are so many
opportunities in this movie for things
to jump out at you to be experienced on
like a full giant screen I think IMAX is
going to really be a pretty spectacular
what is his real magic I'll show you
you
you